this morning as I often do I was
checking out some of the discussions
among our audience on our reddit
discussion forum now 2,500 strong 2,500
of our viewers and listeners regularly
participating there you can check it out
at david pakman.com slash reddit and i
hope that you will subscribe let's go
through just a few of the interesting
stories i found this morning on the
forum number one there's a post from j
473 titled the media is really scaring
me right now and it's a pretty good
explanation of why this user is sort of
scared about what's going on with
corporate media and bias and lack of
objectivity and it's triggered a really
big discussion 29 comments as of this
morning and I think there's already more
and it's a really good important
conversation I would encourage you to
check it out also from our reddit
discussion forum a link to a tweet from
Jeremy Scahill who has said he is
backing out of an appearance on real
time with bill maher because Milo you
napolis the sort of all right poster
child I don't even know what to call him
the authorites provocateur we could call
him my Annapolis is going to be on real
time with bill maher and jeremy scahill
saying he does not want to participate
as a result of that a lot of
conversation going on about that i'm
going to review that again later and
sort of see where people are on that
issue shireen summer user Shireen summer
posted a link to an article talking
about the European rise of populist
parties and how some of them are
inspired by Donald Trump a very
interesting article but I would
encourage you to read and one of the
many interesting things on our reddit
discussion forum an interesting question
from a user on our reddit called Balder
93 reaching out to people who wrote it
third party in the 2016 election and
saying would you do it again if you had
the chance are you planning to vote
third party in 2020 and it's a really
interesting conversation about how
people are feeling about third party
votes after what took place in the 2016
election
with Donald Trump defeating Hillary
Clinton practically speaking because of
seventy seven thousand votes across
three states and then lastly I don't
exactly remember what this is about
there's a post from ftn be 33 on our
budget discussion forum which is called
is david still thinking about getting a
firearm and they go on to say I was
completely shocked when I heard David
say he was considering purchasing a gun
I don't exactly remember what this is in
reference to I do remember at some point
saying it had crossed my mind in certain
situations to say should I look into
getting a firearm and I think I
mentioned at one point that I thought it
would be interesting for the show to
sort of do a mini documentary of me
going through the process to show how
easy or difficult it would end up being
but I don't remember actually saying I'm
thinking about getting a gun in practice
do you remember anything like this pat
well I know that we've talked about you
shooting guns but not necessarily owning
them and I know it's also very difficult
to get a gun here in Boston liberal gun
ownership has actually increased quite
significantly since the election and I
wonder if this reddit user here is
suggesting that that's the reason why
you may be trying to get one now you
grew up Pat in a town outside of Boston
certainly more conservative than Boston
certainly a place where is easier to
have firearms did you did you ever think
about getting a firearm it's never been
an interest of mine I've never shot a
gun I probably should because I think
you would increase my credentials as a
liberal to talk about the topic but I
just I just have no urge to do it
honestly yeah interesting I know that
there is lots of self-described
progressives in our audience who do own
firearms and I have never even implied
that by virtue of having a firearm you
are implicitly more conservative I think
that that political ideology and
individual decisions to own or not own
guns sort of at the abstract level are
two separate things of course it's
undeniable that the overwhelming
majority of so-called gun activists are
politically more conservative join us on
reddit david pakman
/ re d di t I'm on their daily Pat
checks it out and a lot of interesting
stuff happening there